so on sunday night this rolling stone
story broke written researched by hunter
walker
incredible story
outlining the degree to which members of
congress republican members of congress
were actually
allegedly involved in the planning of
the january sixth
protests that turned into the trump
riots and a lot of prominent republicans
were named in that we we heard the name
marjorie taylor greene
lauren beaubert madison cawthorne and
others one of the names we heard was moe
brooks mo brooks is the congressman who
was wearing body armor on january 6th
why do you do that unless you suspect
something pretty crazy is going to
happen still not a question that we've
gotten answered well
mo brooks is doing something that
it tracks with mo brooks and everything
we know about him
he's sort of suggesting maybe it was his
staff that was involved in the planning
of what happened on january 6th
completely throwing them under the bus
this is just absolutely fantastic let's
look at an article about this from
business insider
congressman mo brooks shifted blame onto
his staff
after he was accused of helping to
organize the january 6 capital rally
mo brooks shifted blame to a staff over
his alleged role
in planning the stop the steel rally two
planners told rolling stone that
congressman brooks had been in contact
with organizers for the event
brooks said he had no involvement in
planning it but maybe
maybe his staff had a role
i don't know if my staff did we actually
have a tweet um melanie zanona who's a
capitol hill reporter for cnn tweeted
uh representative mo brooks told me he
had no involvement in planning the
january 6th rally but said
i don't know if my staff did but if they
did
i'd be proud of them for helping to put
together a rally lawful under the first
amendment at the ellipse to protect
protest voter fraud
and election theft
um
brooks was responding to a rolling stone
report that as we told you identified
him as one of the lawmakers involved in
planning the rally outside the capitol
brooks spoke at the event telling the
audience to start quote
taking down names
and kicking ass
he wore body armor as he spoke slate
reported in july
shortly afterward as we now know
hundreds of pro-trump protesters stormed
the capital in a challenge to the
certification of joe biden's election
victory so
why is why is mo brooks doing this first
question is this an act of desperation
by mo brooks throwing his staff under
the bust bus as as his best defense
it may be an act of desperation and what
this relates to is the committee and the
investigation that's going on into
january 6th and the article actually
mentions that the news comes as the
bipartisan congressional investigation
into the events of january 6 heats up
with the panel
moving on monday to pursue criminal
contempt charges against steve bannon
the former trump aide who refused to
share information about any role he may
have played that day
two people who planned that this is we
know this from the article monday
two people who planned the rally
beforehand told rolling stone that
multiple people involved in planning the
stop the steel rallies communicated with
members of congress in the run-up to the
january 6th event one of whom was
michael was uh
was mo brooks uh the planners also said
they'd been in communication with uh
congressman paul gosar lauren bobert
madison cawthorne andy biggs and louis
gohmert brooks has been identified as
being involved in the planning of the
wild protest a separate event
held on january 6 that sought to
challenge biden's election victory in a
now deleted live stream ali alexander
who helped organize it said brooks along
with gozer and biggs had come up with
the idea for the protest so there are so
many different ways in which mo brooks
is being implicated here but just do a
just do a sniff test do like just a
basic gut check
he wants us to believe
that he had no idea anything might go
down
even if his staff were involved in
planning this he didn't know he would be
proud of it but he didn't know but
he just decided to wear body armor on
january 6th
just in case
it doesn't pass the sniff test you've
got to just sometimes do a gut check and
say does this is this even is this even
theoretically plausible
uh and it's not and it's not so where
are there going to be consequences for
someone like mo brooks no probably not
mo brooks is in a uh quite a safe seat
and it doesn't seem that his
constituents have any real interest in
removing him uh in november of 2022 that
continues to be the trend where we learn
more and more
uh and yet there seems to be very little
appetite from the people who could
actually impose consequences on these
folks to really do anything about it
we're going to talk about that a little
more but now let's go to another
revelation regarding this trump riot
committee and as as the previous
discussion mentioned
this is a committee that is really
ramping up over the last seven to ten
days
that i believe is part of why you're
seeing increased desperation from these
people including saying i don't know
maybe my staff was involved which would
be fine but it definitely wasn't me i
had no idea but i did wear body armor
none of these things make any sense
the desperation
the completely kind of unhinged nature
of the allegations that they're making
uh is clearly related to this committee
ramping up let's talk about that next
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies i've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 thousand five star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it you'll get one hundred percent
of your money back because they stand
behind their product you've got nothing
to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to 40 off and free shipping when you go
to 4sigmatic.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video